this is a production of Cornell
University
well thank you very much Andy and thanks
for being here we're going to learn what
I've been doing these past few years all
related to agricultural residue burning
in eastern India
but first
do you know someone with one of these an
iPhone might even be you and if you have
an iPhone I don't I have a cracked
screen Android but if you have an iPhone
the likelihood that you have a Mac
computer your finances might be
integrated into Apple pay or even have a
Apple watch makes it really difficult if
a better technology comes abroad on
board whether it's related to price
longevity camera and Android but anyway
I won't go into phone politics there but
this is something that we call
technological lock-in
and What technological lock-in is is it
makes it difficult to transition out of
something that you're already already in
and there are some examples in
agriculture as well so a really classic
example in agriculture is John Deere
equipment and the integrated software
platform so once that farmer it takes
this big capital investment into the
tractor and has their whole Data Systems
and data management integrated it makes
it really difficult to train you know
switch brands but we can even extend
this definition
to the context of crop residue burning
crop residue burning and rice systems in
India
is a practice to that allows you to
Quick blouse Farmers to quickly remove
the residue of rice once the grain is
harvested to quickly plant in the
subsequent crop of Wheat and this reply
this practice replaces the traditional
practice of manually harvesting bundling
the straw and carrying it back into the
homestead for livestock uses and other
uses
and here's the lock-in part that once
Farmers adopt burning it makes it very
difficult for them to transition usually
on a more of an economic reason into
something like a Baler or a happy Cedar
which is a instrument or a mechanism
that allows picks up the residue and
allows Farmers to plant wheat into the
the heavy residue load
and so it makes it very difficult so to
give you a little bit more context of
the problem of burning burning the main
hot spot of burning in India happens in
the Northwest in Punjab and haryana
every year unfortunately there's a major
winter air quality crisis in the city of
Delhi
um and it's gotten a lot of a lot of
issues gotten a lot of attention for
good reason
now if you look at the satellite data
and take a look at where our area of
work is and Bihar states in the east
the density is is not burning isn't as
frequent but what's alarming and why
we're interested in studying this is
because the rate of burning is
increasing rapidly over the last two
decades
now burning has long-term implications
for nutrient availability in the soil
but the major issue with residue burning
is the air pollution so in a very simple
sense
the particulate matter particularly the
particulate matter of 2.5 microns or
less causes major health health issues
and so in Delhi in the peak Burning
Season
the air pollution almost 42 on average
is coming from burning which is really a
massive amount
and if we look at some of the the worst
polluted cities in India we see of
course Delhi listed up there towards the
top but Patna in the largest city in
Bihar the capital city is right next to
it and that's without
all the additional uh burning and the
pollution from the burning
and so in the Northwest it's been a
pervasive problem even though government
has made regulation but investments into
equipment it's been really difficult to
stop and get Farmers transitioned out of
it they're essentially locked in and so
for us it's an opportunity to get ahead
of this problem and prevent the lock-in
situation in the east
so my research can be grouped into three
main bundles first we want to know what
what is happening so far burning in East
India has been understudied and so we
want to know what's been happening
across space and time
and then why why is burning on the rise
and finally if we're not burning it now
what there needs to be we need to look
at other Pathways and all of these
pieces are meant to inform uh policy
design and get ahead of the impending
issue
so we'll start with the what so we're
looking at what has happened in Bihar
across space and time since 2002 that's
that's the earliest that we have
satellite information or that we're
using satellite information-wise so to
see what's been happening burning
related to burning
but we also the next two components of
this work are related to
understanding what would happen
mid-century if business as usual
continued and then look at that scenario
as well as a couple other scenarios to
simulate air quality outcomes sure if it
if it increases what does that actually
mean for public health it puts a real
meaning and some real urgency behind
things and that was done with our
atmospheric Sciences collaborators to
using transport modeling to model
implications for public health burden
the methods use two main satellite
products Modis and beers Modis has a
longer time series since 2002
but a fairly coarse resolution at one
kilometer whereas beers has a time a
shorter time series we can't look back
as far but it has a finer spatial
resolution and so it's capturing more
fires
and then those two data sets
are used with ground observations
and really relate to what that what that
means for emission wise for in
particular particularly for air
pollution
so our first step is quantify buyers
over space space and time and then the
second step is then to estimate the
impacts mid-century
so four the results show
just
from a visual observation you know the
font's a little small in the back but
from 2012 15 18. not only are we seeing
fires increasing in the Southwest
but we're also seeing fires spreading
across
to the east basically
when we look at this quantitatively
across time
in the gray
the x-axis we have the years and on the
y-axis we have the burn area and in the
gray we can see that from our historic
knowledge of fires and what we're seeing
from the satellite data that fires are
nearly doubling we're also seeing the
very interesting pattern
probably see it this up down this kind
of extreme inner annual variability so
not only are they increasing they have
this interesting nature about them so we
did some empirical modeling
to say what that would what that could
look like mid-century if business as
usual continues and these fires
from 2020 to 2050 we're looking at
potentially 142 percent increase
but now we want to see what that means
for public health and air pollution
so this is our scenario analysis we
looked at three main scenarios
ideally all the burning that has taken
up taken place up to now we want to stop
all right that's like present day levels
of course we'd love to stop everything
but let's say we just no more
progression the levels that they're at
right now let's keep them there that was
our first scenario
second scenario reflects back to the
previous slide that increase
and then the Northwest analog is
something
that we'd like to compare the area
burned to what is happening in the
Northwest so if burning got as bad on an
area basis as Punjab and haryana what
would that mean for air quality
and I'll draw your attention to those
three Circle there those three main
scenarios and we're looking at this we
the way we look at this is in exceedance
days so we look at pollution thresholds
PM 2.5
and we look at two different thresholds
we have the world World Health
Organization which has a more
conservative value on what's exceedance
for PM 2.5 and then then the Indian
national air quality standard
and when we look at the number of
exceeding stays just for burning alone
so this is not
traffic this is not industrial this is
burning alone that we can see in the
Northwest analog there's up to 45 days
of students again out of 92 within the
three-month period that are expected to
be 42 days or 40 almost 45 days above
that threshold
now we looked at a couple other things
as well and I'll just give you a little
Glimpse on some of the other things we
looked at
and also I think it's a pretty this
model has a really cool output with the
lines there so what this is is a
five-day back trajectory of winds so we
know the winds are going to carry these
pollutants
and making a cute Arab air pollution
events more prevalent and so and we also
know that
the location of the Burns in in Bihar in
the southwest are fairly close proximity
to the main city so depending on the air
condition the wind conditions for
example the winds it can cause some
pretty big issues in acute events in the
city so it's not just about these
overall averages but it's also these
like really bad days depending on what
other conditions are adding to the issue
and carrying those pollutants
so the key message to this first piece
of the work is
burning is in fact on the rise
unfortunately and burning up present
levels can be easily overlooked but if
we if if uh creative and Urgent policy
interventions are not implemented it
could result in a mid-century air
quality crisis particularly during the
winter months
but from this work this is something
that we call a naive analysis so we're
we're really interested in the point
pattern process how that's moving across
space and time it doesn't give us any
insight into why and that's what leads
us
into the next piece the why
we want to know the drivers of Vernon
why what is where is this residue going
particularly related to burning and what
are the drivers at the household and
across the landscape and then here's the
the tricky part well that's tricky as
well but here's the here's the tricky
part is okay we're in a system in Bihar
that is
that is developing their structural
transformation taking place their system
changes related to labor and livestock
that are going to be influencing the
systems so it's not only important for
us to understand what the drivers are
and identify them but understand how
they relate and the order and the
sequence of change in the system and
that will hopefully give us some really
some much deeper understanding of where
uh certain policy interventions could be
targeted
so to begin to understand this complex
system
we used
a very
a very detailed interaction model or
description here and I please don't
attempt to read this because you might
get a little headache but I'll walk you
through some major components here the
first thing we're seeing related to
burning is labor changes if you look at
the farmer there bundling the straw this
is the typical this is the traditional
way of handling these residues the the
these residues are manually harvested
bundled carried back for the to the
homestead
it's very labor intensive and as labor
is becoming more expensive or less
readily available or labor in the
household the amount of available
individuals in the household to do
agricultural labor labor is decreasing
it opens the need for mechanized options
which is the main one here is the
combine harvester although there's some
other intermediary
mechanism mechanization options as well
such as their Reaper but the combine
harvester is
is the big one
but here's the the issue with the
combine harvester instead of having
these nice long stalks that are easy to
store but the livestock enjoy that's a
perception held perception
um the combine takes the whole plant
threshes it chops it up throws it out
the back so these residues are now
shorter bent more difficult to pick up
and so it's just a lot more difficult to
handle and the quality is is down and
then and then livestock so these systems
the crop the crop and Livestock systems
are quite intertwined so our one of our
initial hypotheses was
perhaps these systems are decoupling a
bit at the household and so you have
these areas of deficit and surplus for
the residue
potentially
um livestock numbers are going down so
there's an overall more of a deficit or
a surplus sorry for a residues
the one thing with why we're studying
this issue in the east as well and I'll
just take a side note here is in the
Northwest it's been it's a major issue
and it's it's been there's been a lot of
studies to try to understand the drivers
in the Northwest and it's highly
related to the combine use but in these
systems the farm sizes are smaller
the combine can't get into all the
fields because the farm sizes are the
fields are fragmented it's wetter like
they can't the machine can't get in on
time as well and so
there's these dynamics that make this
ecology different and why we need to
why you need to take a deeper look at it
and then there's Agronomy issues too
with changing climates potentially
different types of varieties we have a
shorter window to harvest the wheat and
or harvest the rice and then plant the
wheat so there's all these aspects we're
looking at and considering
and to do this
this was a true mixed method study
mixed methods meaning
both quantitative and qualitative
so right before the pandemic we didn't
know the pandemic was coming we were in
the field talking with key informants
Farmers as a very preliminary
understanding to develop our household
surveys
we also have our partners in in country
Summit sisa who have been collecting
what is called a crop diagnostic survey
so we have some type of idea of what the
typical management yields and so forth
are in the region and these were used to
inform our quantitative survey the crop
residue burning survey which then added
some additional components so related to
labor livestock right all those things
residue markets that I had mentioned
earlier
we did it twice the second one
was informed by the results and findings
of the first so further refined and then
ultimately we used the 400 the second
survey with 475 respondents for our
random forest and then coupled that with
the remotely sensed data
and then for the qualitative piece we
went into one specific District in buxar
buxar is an area you can see that in
Orange there an area where burning is
prevalent and the combine is available
so not everywhere in this in this state
is the combine even available so we
wanted to make sure we had all the
possible factors and something that was
really interesting is
there are some people who are using the
combine but not burning why are they not
burning like that's a really important
thing that's happening that we don't
really understand and we we needed to
under we needed to at least get some
more insight into that so these were
semi-structured interviews 18 households
the male and female head of household
were interviewed by female interviewers
separately and that was to get a sense
of the decision-making process within
the household
but let's take a look at the
quantitative
there's a quantitatively for the random
Forest a series of predictor variables
were selected these were again related
to livestock related to household number
of individuals in the household the
market integration of that household for
example the amount of AG income
share of the household integration into
the residue Market are they selling
residues are they buying residues for
their livestock and so forth and then of
course this was aimed at
uh trying to understand our Target
variable farmer reported burning
now is all good researchers as we are so
we we realize that things don't always
happen the way we want them to and in
fact
we over sampled so that we would have a
population of burners those farmers who
have burned in the past we only actually
had five respondents in that last survey
that admitted to burning this is for a
couple of reasons one well
it's a trust reason essentially so the
government of Bihar has made no burn
regulation and there has been some
efforts on enforcement I'll talk about
that a little bit later but essentially
these households were nervous about
admitting to burning and potentially
having punitive pressure but we know
through remote sensing and more
importantly conversations with people on
the ground that burning is quite
prevalent in some of these areas
and so then we had to go back to our
remotely sensed data
it is difficult to study fires and I
showed you this plot earlier and the
reality is this plot while that has you
know a few fires on it's missing
potentially up to 75 percent of the
small fires right so we kind of know
what's happening we can kind of it gives
us a representative idea across time of
the trends but it's hard to say that
household burned and this is because
these fires are small they last half
hour
uh they use satellite depending
depending on the instrument there might
be only two or four passes a day and
they're also
crossing over in a season where there's
more Haze and there's more clouds and so
there's a lot of omissions in these
observations so we did an exercise using
a combination of satellite products
using and using spatial analysis using a
smoothing exercise kernel density
estimation to create a burn likelihood
So based on where that house that
household is located within the state
they are given it's given a value on a
scale of one to zero burn being more
likely if what a one and then we paired
this with the GPS point of the household
surveys to at least give us some type of
connection and GAP fill a little bit of
this this air so instead of the farmer
reporting
farmer reported burning for our Target
variable which would have been ideal
we then use the satellite derived burn
likelihood value so it's just a way to
to gut feel and get a little creative I
guess there
so for the random Forest results our
model explained 32 percent of the
variance
the model explained 32 which is which is
fairly low and considering our Target
how we came up with our Target value we
also know that we're probably missing
some things that are happening in the
landscape that weren't included as
predictors in our in our model but
I have one single regression tree
remember random Force has multiple trees
but this is one example of how the model
is thinking about these factors so our
first split is for Farmers with more
than 10 percent of their rice area
combine harvested
they're more likely to burn
and I'll just note that a lot of these
farmers
the combine use versus manual use is
usually not a binary it's usually a
percentage of each again it depends on
the timing on the availability on the
entry in the field entry and and
livestock so the second split here is
with livestock so as livestock
um
as as the house will have more livestock
higher density they were less likely to
burn giving Insight that livestock would
give that farmers were choosing to
manually Harvest potentially or
um with more livestock
but we can also look at this with
variable the variable importance plot
again you can see that combine livestock
rise to the top but I'll show you I want
your attention to go to that third
variable there harvest date
on the right we're looking at partial
dependency plot so we went to see how
harvest date relates to burn likelihood
on the y-axis and what's interesting is
we see this very clear ledge here
this ledge saying that once you get to
once that farmer gets to a certain
harvest date
so a late Harvest of rice there's a real
urgency to remove that residue and get
the wheat in farmers are very aware that
they yield their wheat yields and
profitability are dependent on getting
the wheat planted in on time so I think
this is something that is is quite
variable year to year
and something that is something that
should be considered in this decision
now this quantitative work was useful it
gave us insights to the predictors
it's although it did only explain a
small amount of the variance so we know
there's some things missing and we need
to do some further work and that's why
we went into the qualitative piece as
well as
quantitatively it's very difficult to
understand the order of change processes
and so this is where the qualitative
piece came in
so moving into step two this is one of
our some of our Farmers that we're
speaking with along with our
collaborators and anthropologists
but we used these systems are very
complex right and so we really needed to
figure out a framework
that we could systematically look at
Farmers decision making so we use this
framework of their livelihoods platform
approach because Farmers decision making
at various levels from the household
Community institution are interdependent
on the resources available let it be
human physical Financial informational
and so this gave us a framework to
develop our semi-structured interviews
and then also create a code book and and
analyze the results in a very systematic
way
so here's our results and we're really
again we're looking at the sequence of
the drivers related to burning
we have Labor and livestock coming up as
as the initial changes in the system
which is interesting our quantitative
work didn't really capture the changes
related to labor but we saw this a lot
more in our qualitative work so for
example
if labor was low in the household or
even if they wanted to hire labor to
manually Harvest their fields and it
wasn't available for multiple reasons
they were more likely to adopt the
combine and we were seeing uh low labor
and livestock at the household
decreasing now labor also relates to
livestock because if there's less
household labor available the likelihood
that they're going to keep in 10 the
livestock goes down and and so
while the other side of that is if
there's high levels of livestock more
household labor in particular the
decision to manually Harvest is or the
percentage of area manually harvested
increases
and this the Harvest method is really
key to determining the value of straw
whereas if it's manually harvested you
have the the straw maintaining value as
a fodder or other some other household
purposes as well
um but if it's combine harvested the
primary pathway is
burning that it's really viewed as a as
a waste product unless
it's fed by fodder or fed as Potter
excuse me we also asked Farmers okay we
have this problem like what what would
your solution to burning be Farmers
really struggled to try to figure many
of them responding there there are no
there are no options like we have no
choice we have this is our livelihood we
have to get our wheat planted on time
and
um and we also
of course captured the gender lens the
household decision making process
through all of this
I will show you really some really
interesting quotes came out of this work
but I'll I'll point to this idea that
it's difficult to solve these problems
with with policies for no burn and then
trying to trying to reinforce and trying
to enforce excuse me no burn policies we
have respondents saying we have no fear
of anyone coming to enforce these rules
we can burn
um I can this is my land so I'm burning
the straw in my land
another responded the second one there
said help people in the community do
burn but there's great concern that
they're going to have essentially
punitive action against them
and then I think what's really
interesting this last sentence
government officers came here but no one
is ready to stop this process this
Burning process this respondent later
inferred that
oftentimes that Enforcer
is their buddy nice right rural places
they have farming to do as well
but in the sense that they have residue
to remove as well and then also some
Community Action where farmers will burn
at the same time and then meet The
Enforcer at one time burn at night so
there's these things are
difficult to enforce
so the key message is Farmers don't have
um useful and accessible solutions to
and Alternatives and the best solution
and where we think there's an
opportunity for policy intervention is
creating value around straw to preserve
the quality of straw and
and think about how you use the system
of changes to inform how strong could be
valued
so with all this
remember
we want to facilitate no burn Pathways
that one are responsive to the changing
crop livestock system that the last
component the last the second piece just
um
clarified
and we want to create value around draw
so the third piece looks at Pathways
forward
so imagine we have the rice residue and
we have three we can group The Pathways
in the three main groups we can burn it
we want to avoid that
we can handle that residue off the field
to remove it feed it to livestock or
other purposes
or we can keep it on the field and
manage it in the field and when we look
at this from a labor perspective that's
often the easiest
and there are there is some additional
value there potentially so one by
keeping carbon in the soil we're adding
carbon to the soil there's a potential
for ergonomic games gains now of course
this is complex in itself and the study
doesn't particularly dive too deep into
that
what it does dive into is the potential
greenhouse gas benefits of building
carbon in the soil and then potentially
we're in the context and environment
right now where there could be
potentially carbon financing
that could potentially
be involved in this as well uh but but
one thing in these systems is
their race systems right systems are
generally wet systems which then are
more prone to methane and the trade-offs
of adding carbon into the systems
becomes a little bit more complex
and that's what this third and last
paper
um body of work I should say go looks at
and looks at various post-harvest
residue pathways
I'm drying out
of talking
um
and so it looks at various pathways
but specifically looks at in-situ
management and the effect of hydrology
on carbon Management in these systems
and then Compares and contrasts all
these Pathways to more understand more
completely understand the conditional
value of residue in these systems from
the greenhouse gas perspective
all right I'm going to share with you
some field realities and Bihar related
to hydrology
now I'll focus a little bit more on this
aspect in today's presentation because
it it's
often overlooked when we're looking at
greenhouse gas Accounting in these types
of systems so here is a dry flooded and
saturated field situation these are
pipes where 30 centimeter pipes there we
go where 15 centimeters above surface
level 15 centimeters below and every day
measurements can be taken in that pipe
to give us a sense of the water level in
that field now the thing with water is
that it creates an anaerobic environment
which opens up
which allows methane to be produced in
that anaerobic environment and in the
most simple sense we're adding carbon
into the system which is essentially
giving more fuel to these microbes to
then produce more methane so that's the
type of reality that we're we're trying
to understand now in Bihar
a field might go through all of these in
just a matter of a couple days
that there's these are not irrigated
systems but we have lateral flow we have
precipitation of course and these are
these are um determined by sole
properties but also the position in the
landscape as well and in fact our lab's
looking into how to better characterize
this but for our general sense this is
kind of gives you a sense of what this
field might look like so nine sites here
and this is just day by day in the field
during the rice season you can see sites
one and six there
we call flashy dry dry wet dry wet dry
wet and so when we're trying to
calculate methane emissions in general
it's
it's challenging and we really do can
use things like Dynamic models to
understand these these are very
difficult scenarios and realities to try
to
to try to create an experiment a farm
for example
so our this study looks at
the different Pathways and it uses it
uses primarily tier one accounting
approaches so fairly basic standard
coefficients to understand
live livestock Pathways infield
off-field management
but with the soil component and the
water component we have an opportunity
to dive a little bit deeper and compare
that with tier three approaches and so
what we what we have here to work with
is we want to understand
we want to understand carbon returns in
the field under different hydrologies so
we have a data set 2020
no whole distribution of flooded and dry
and we on that distribution selected a
dry median and wet site that's our
categories
but we know that there's a lot of inner
annual these fields look very different
in different climate years so we
actually have three years of data and we
did the same thing picked it on a
distribution when we ran this model for
a hundred years
each year we would randomly select model
year we would randomly select a
hydrology year so for example 2020 was a
very wet year and then 2022 probably
that was like super dry drought year and
so not only are we
wanting to see the methane differences
and the net ghg balance
of these different hydrologies we want
to get a sense of you know be realistic
in the fact these are going to change
year to year
so we had our hydrologies we looked at
the residue retention it was a treatment
so 10 double only versus 100 residue
return
and then we looked at uh yields as well
so current yields versus intensive
intensified or higher yields it's
essentially if you're returning more
fresh carbon that's going to matter as
well as more active biomass growing
you're going to have more methane
um released
so here's here's our results we have the
hydrologist grouped on the x-axis and we
have the cumulative
seasonal average methane flux in blue we
have no residue treatments and in green
we have the residue treatment
and as we expected wetter environments
median and wet there have much higher
methane methane overall methane flex but
I what's really interesting here is that
when you add residues back into those
systems you have
in wetter environments you have a much
more range of possibilities where if you
add that residue into a drier
environment on a methane perspective
it's fairly
negligible to the
thus no residue treatment or the double
only treatment
but the big question is particularly
from the carbon Market standpoint is are
we by adding carbon into these systems
is there more of a net positive flux
through methane and nitrous oxide as
compared to building SOC so organic
carbon and where is that where's that
balance that ideally
we know that
these options are better than burning
from a public health standpoint
that that straw needs to go somewhere
else but
we're looking at these dry conditions
it's close to zero that balance is close
to zero in the first few years but then
it starts to increase into a net
positive flux and in the wetter
environments it the flux is the the net
is much different
so the key message is that field
hydrology has a controlling effect on
methane in particular and that when
we're when we're guiding Farmers towards
towards Pathways that we need to be very
context specific and perhaps understand
the landscape place carbon in the dryer
environment
um
and just be very clear about the
expected outcomes now I will say these
results are early we're working on these
results and these are in systems where
there's still tillage we're looking to
it's following similar current farmer
practices what's actually doable right
now
um and these are tropical soils right so
there's there's many there's many
factors at play and I'm just giving you
a glimpse of some of these comparisons
but it gets us thinking a little bit
more about how
how complex this
um situations are
so in conclusion here
this work in totality
help describe what's happening in Bihar
for the first time across space and time
with burning which was a really neat I
think I'm a little biased but I think
was an interest a very interesting
perspective we got a sense of the
drivers of burning and how that relates
to the change processes in the system
and then from a greenhouse gas
standpoint we're getting a perspective
of how these different Pathways prepare
but still in the context of anything is
better than burning essentially and the
most simplest conclusion
but I would like to take a couple couple
uh moments here to have a big picture
reflection with you all
that this research was an opportunity to
get ahead of a problem oftentimes in
agriculture where we're addressing big
hairy issues and this was an opportunity
to understand it a problem while it's
smaller or in its infancy to hopefully
understand it to bend the trajectories
and to to prevent something that's quite
quite unsustainable at a very large
level and that might be something that
you could think about for your own
research as well I think it's a very
interesting how is it if we're really
looking at making our Ag Systems more
sustainable it's a really interesting
approach to take
but speaking of complex systems
and you mentioned this earlier
This research
really Embrace multi-disciplinary
collaborations I think I think it had to
to actually give the complexity of this
system and under to give it to give it
justice to really pull apart all these
complex pieces
and my background was in the social
sciences so I was a little bit keen on
that and I got really analytical really
quick with my work which is also good
stretched me quickly but at the same
time like we we know these these
collaborations are challenging worked
very closely with atmospheric scientists
here at Cornell and then also our our
social scientist partner and Country and
timelines vary sometimes it takes a
little bit longer to have these
conversations sometimes creative tension
comes up in a good way right and it's
it's best in the long term but I I think
when we're working with these AG Systems
we are in fact working with systems and
it's worth embracing embracing that
aspect
so with that thank you very much I have
a special thank you I want to say a
special thank you to the soil and crop
this section faculty and staff I know
we're all running on passion and a
little bit of pressure and I just want
to appreciate the time that you all have
taken to talk to me about this work
other work realities of sleepless nights
with an infant and I appreciate you
taking your time out of your days and
creating the supportive environment so
thank you
questions from the floor
they're officially two men but I'm sure
that Emily will stick around
thank you so much nice presentations
alterational learning all the people
will help people or
animal or birds in the area
oh so the question was is there any are
there any effect of birding on the the
people and you're thinking on people
animals in the area are thinking in
addition to the pollution
is that like the air any sociological
effects supposed to possible negative in
living in this area local people and
animals and birds in the area there are
effects I
interesting perspective on Wildlife I've
given very little thought of the
wildlife but if you're thinking in the
animals around and the people around
um I think
yeah I I think other than the pollution
you would imagine that that pollution
the air quality would affect livestock
as well and the productivity of the farm
animals around
um as far as a livelihood strategy it's
a very unfortunately it's a very quick
way light a match your problem of
dealing with this massive residue load
is gone
so because of that it's it's easily
adopted but it's
yeah obviously we don't want that
direction so it's almost a benefit at
the cost right yep thank you I think I
saw did I see Ying I think I saw your
hand yeah I have any questions about the
first of all week
so
the first question is about related to
your first uh project so I wonder like
how you build a model that uh which way
I think the requirements
um that we utilize to travel into the
future I think that model is
black box at this one thing yeah that's
my first question and well the third
appointment
is
that you're utilizing models to look at
the differences right among the
scenarios I wonder if there that has
been um validated with independent
experiments that you verify the
differences
right right okay so those are two great
questions first was related to the in
the first paper the the data the
admissions data set was very critical to
our final results and what's actually
going on there and the second questions
related to the
um oh my goodness I'm blanking them
um but let me start with the first first
uh the with the admissions data set
we have
it's our partner are not Partners um a
group in Harvard put together that data
site or that emissions data set that was
the first effort there are a couple
different data sets that relate fires to
emissions and this was a data set that
Gap filled because a lot of those didn't
include ground truthing and even this
this the building of that data set also
included household surveys this is
before a lot of the no burn regulation
came up so farmers were admitting to
burning in their study and so we we are
we are trusting that that is the best
emissions data source that we have from
that group that has been heavily
involved in burning and idea and then
for your your second question the second
question was related to are we
validating the results for dndc and
those those questions there and and our
lab group is at large looking to do that
from the hydrology perspective because
at this point it's it is very
challenging like I said too
to try to match their so and those
realities of field realities hydrologies
that I showed you were all within a very
small geographic area in Bihar so it's
just like the amount of variability is
quite extreme
um so that's part of what our lab group
is looking to better characterize but I
I will mention that we
the ABS as far as this modeling exercise
finding absolute terms it's the it's
loose but it does give us some idea of
comparison inner comparison between the
treatments
enjoyed it I have a couple of questions
do you uh relate the VR situation with
Northwest India and you mentioned about
the earning continuous learning there so
there's the policy of planting those
rice in Northwest India with the
planting dates you have to go with
is there such a state policy in Bihar
that is implemented
how that is affecting the burning
and second question
uh how the state agencies playing a role
in educating The Producers or the small
holding crops uh on this topic
agency yeah and the farmers so the first
question was that the there's very
strict regulation in the Northwest on
planting times to to keep the system in
order in that way I'm not familiar Andy
is there back me up on this
and Bihar there's no such and that's
because of the underground water decline
as part of
the whole
composite
right I'm not sure in Bihar what's
happening
and not in Northwest right
right Andy has done quite a bit of work
looking at the groundwater
um aspect and relating that relationship
but in be harmed no Could It Go that
direction potentially and you mentioned
about the happy season
not not common in Bihar and part of it
and is on the edge of the seat wants to
jump in gotta let the grass student talk
because being just being tough on you
um but it is it'd be hard you're dealing
with smaller field sizes that have
had smaller the mechanization the
tractors are much smaller and the happy
Cedar is very very horsepower requires a
lot of horsepower and so there's a gap
there and then the the amount of
service providers in that small window
it's very limited
and yeah the happy Cedar has a huge as
you know huge discussion in the
Northwest about economics and the timely
accessibility to it and all of that so
it's complex did you want to jump in him
no okay I'm mindful of time we should
let we should thank Emily and give her
one more round of applause
if anybody has any questions keep Emily
out now and stick around a few more
minutes of course
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu